you know the drill by now we're about to
hit a new month which means we're
getting new playstation plus games I'm
Tony and this is your April lineup first
up ps4 owners are getting drawn to death
the next game from twisted metal and God
of War creator david jaffe the arena
shooter launches next week so you PS
plus members get a brand-new game for
free you'll also get the co-op action
game lovers in a dangerous space time
the ps3 is getting the platformer
invizimals the Lost Kingdom and the
first person shooter alien rage extended
edition and on the portable side PS Vita
is getting the action puzzler 10-second
ninja and the brawler curses in chaos
thanks to cross by you can also play
both of those on ps4 and be sure to
subscribe to be the first to know about
all the PS Plus offerings every month
the April games well be live on the PSN
store on Tuesday April fourth until then
you can grab marches games including
disk jam and tearaway unfolded and to
see what's new on the Xbox side of
things you can always check out our
games with gold and backwards compatible
videos
[Music]